cqfd ce qui fait débat c'est un projet
qui est réalisé avec le soutien du fonds
citoyen franco allemand on va
s'intéresser aux relations franco
allemandes et à différents thèmes
d'actualité on va voir comment ça se
passe en france en allemagne en matière
d'environnement d'énergie de dépenses
militaires de lutte contre l'homophobie
aussi ou encore l'accueil des réfugiés
on parlera aussi gastronomie et la
culture sensation va être mobilisée mais
on va également faire appel à des sens à
reporter
[Musique]
pour devenir sens à reporter faudra nous
envoyer une courte vidéo d'environ une
minute et nous raconter donc votre
vision des relations franco allemandes
si votre vidéo et sélectionnez vous
pourrez participer avec radio sensations
à des ateliers la maison de l'europe des
yvelines sur l'union européenne sur
l'évolution des relations franco
allemandes et puis on réalisera aussi
des reportages et des interviews avec
toute la rédaction donc tout le monde
peut être participer que vous soyez
lycéens étudiants retraités ou même
jeunes ou plus âgées toutes les
générations seront les bienvenus dans ce
projet alors des allemands pour en venir
en france faire des interviews et des
reportages notamment pendant un festival
de musique en essonne les primeurs de
massy et puis les français nous
accompagnerons à berlin et à
aschaffenburg qui est d'ailleurs la
ville jumelée avec saint germain en laye
on va réaliser plusieurs numéros
spéciaux de notre émission zone europe
qui est diffusée aussi sur tv 118 ça
sera les 3 10 et 17 décembre prochain et
puis on va proposer une semaine spéciale
du 5 au 9 décembre on va diffuser toute
une série d'interviews et de reportages
sur les antennes de radio sensations en
ile-de-france et en normandie est pour
réaliser tout ça on s'est associé à
asheville institut des hautes études de
journalisme à montpellier radio club
berthe en allemagne une radio locale à
aschaffenburg et puis également à la
maison de l'europe des idées
[Musique]